well that's my deepest passion is the
year what we can know about God through
through reason through the use of our
own intelligence through a soft
questioning coming to know who we are
ourselves and I wrote about this book as
one of my first books in 1965 belief and
unbelief of course which one I get a
chance to teach I still love to teach
time you know the research institute now
not teaching and and then later some
years later a book called the experience
of nothingness dealing especially with
the problem of why is it that nihilists
write books I mean there's no meaning to
anything and it's all observed in chaos
and relative they certainly write with a
passion for honesty and and courage
they're always praising courage and and
writing books is a great active
community so it seems to me in the heart
of nihilism there's a powerful positive
ethic of honesty and courage and
communities and it's not enough ethic
that carry you all through life doesn't
tell you much about men or women for
example but we're children you know
where's a lot you have to learn but
nonetheless it's the root of a powerful
ethic and I thought I was hoping some
university or institution would invite
me to give a set of lectures so I could
revisit these problems again and that
wasn't happening so I had you know
certain ideas and tentative explorations
and the outbreak of the new atheist
books I wanted to avoid it because I
wasn't my idea wasn't to reply to them
so much but they provided the occasion
for me I getting back in and for that
reason I'm very grateful to them they
raised some good objections that force
believers to think I'd rethink and and
that's all to the good so I love that
problem I think I've enjoyed working on
this book as much as any in my lifetime
and I wanted it to be very good because
it's my last one maybe you know I always
think that way now that I'm 75 do the
best I can but who knows when it
when it's over what I there are a couple
reviewers who have said of it what
pleased me the most that they're
atheists and this book strengthen them
in their atheism but they appreciated
the chance to think each problem through
there were this journey this climb up
the mountain whatever you want takes a
lot of twists and turns into valleys and
so forth and of the mind is is many
mountains and and they appreciated
making that voyage and that's my idea
that that believers and unbelievers I'm
not talking about Judaism and
Christianity now but just philosophy
yeah what but humans can learn of God
just by their own experience if we could
learn to argue about that civilly and
present the evidence of one on the other
to us we would help each other out and
then we would need to come to different
conclusions of no doubt I think the vast
majority would come to the knowledge of
God around them and within them because
that's the default position of the human
race that's what most people have always
done that's what most people on earth
are doing today atheism is a relatively
small minority hold it even agnosticism
and even there you discover opinion
surveys show that one half of all
agnostic actually believe in God in the
way that Aristotle did were Plato or
Cicero or Seneca not the Christian God
not to do as God but an extraordinary
power and really a governor of the
universe in some extraordinary way
paradoxical way often and a great source
of the light and intelligence which
fuses all things whatever this God is
who whose energy you see everywhere he's
he certainly embodies the genius and
mathematics because you study everything
it seems to have it lend itself to
mathematical treatment to an
extraordinary and beautiful a degree
well anyway and even atheists about one
out of every five believes in a god like
Aristotle and
play-doh so you know I do think that's
the default position but for various
reasons people are looking for a
different sort of God and there are five
six ten different ideas of God and most
them just don't work and if you go
seeking those you're not going to
believe in that God for sure and if you
think yourself all you are is a sack of
matter of chemical you know in spirited
for a while and then poof your idea of
God is going to be very limited to in
short I think self knowledge is the key
I look for the everywhere my god san
agustin wrote and when I found the that
worked within and I think that's the key
today so as we see a little bit more
cleaning who we are we either see that
we are participating living in God or or
not and and when I say see you know it's
not the knowledge of the senses you
can't touch God or taste him will see
him or hear him little children do and
people who become religious often filled
a great sweetness and joy for a time but
those who are adult in the faith no long
periods of dryness in them desert as
it's often called when they cry out to
God and there's no reply where they ask
God and then nothing or they approach
God and no one appears they're common in
the biblical period in in all periods of
human history so the kind of knowing we
have of God is a dark knowing it's not
sense knowledge knowing but yeah there
it is it's very strong and very it just
keeps reappearing in human history the
sense of the transcendent of the
numinous of the sacred does a lot more
going on in our lives then
so then we see at first glance and
longer we live the more Reseda